what's great about it is that um you see
the great struggle for gay people i
think was the politics is just not going
to work for us that the idea that these
politicians will bring us equality has
always been a complete delusion the only
thing that brings us equality is our own
testimony in our own lives I've always
believed this although I do think we
have a politics and that what I try to
do in the 90s was to redefine gay
politics by focusing on what I by
getting away from victimhood and the new
left's interpretation of homosexuality
who I think was the truth about it and
and our emotional core as human beings
not that there is anything wrong with
sex I love sex I think sex is completely
absurdly demonized in our culture but in
the end however much sex you want to
have how many people in however many
ways to be loved and to love is what
human beings really want and when I
first started talking about gay marriage
most of people in the gay community
looked at me as if I was insane or
possibly a fascist reactionary whereas
the next generation of gay men and gay
women just I think I've internalized
understood that of course it's their
right to do this why would they not and
that's happening 20 years that is a
shift profound shift in self
consciousness and that shift in self
consciousness has affected the
consciousness of everybody else
especially our families you know would
my father have ever moved from one
position to another were not for his son
telling him the truth I don't think so
and that's our strength unlike other
minorities we're totally embedded in the
majority every generation is born into
for the most part a heterosexual family
so and therefore we have such cultural
power so the argument was always yes
these are the politics this is what we
need but we if we think we're going to
get this through paying these Democratic
Party markers you know all this money
like the human rights campaign or
the group's do be crazy what we're going
to do is so shift public consciousness
so that we now you know we've gone from
like fifteen percent support for
marriage rights in 1989 to fifty two
percent today we have seventy five
percent support phase openly serving in
the military we have like eighty percent
support for non discrimination and
employment and yet we still have
politicians that can't do it and I think
our goal is simply to forget those
politicians and that's why this sort of
this worshipping of of Obama or of
clinton or of these Democratic figures
to me is is really it is really kind of
a sad atif active of the gay need still
to feel worthy um in the end we will
serve him so remade the society it will
have to adjust to us because it will
seem absurd not to and the only weapon
they have against us is fundamentalist
religion in its crudest and rather
brutal form and of course just the
general constancy of the general panic
and fear of anything different which is
a human constant but if you change the
society in the culture the politics will
follow and that's why this kind of thing
it gets better is fantastic that's why
all the social media has been fantastic
because you know it's also one thing to
see a celebrity or some kind of
character on TV show being gay it's a
totally different thing when you know
your husband not your house that your
brother or your friend or the dude you
hung out with high school is gay I mean
that that is what changes people's minds
so I've always believed in a way that if
every gay person really did come out it
will be over